[Music]
what's going on guys you know what it's
June
that means we're just about halfway
through the calendar year 2017 so that
got us thinking what are the best movies
of the year so far because there have
been some good ones we're going to talk
about that very subject today and we
have two of my favorite critics nay two
of my favorite humans here to talk about
that very subject first this guy you
know them as one of the titular schmoes
from schmoes know which one am i the
cute one Mark Ellis and you know we're
from film struck and you can check out
her new book backwards and in heels
which is a history of women in cinema
holy SH I'm alone hi thanks for having
me back so you guys we asked you to
compile basically your 10 best list so
let's talk about a couple films that you
guys both had on your list right off the
bat this film box-office critical
acclaim get out when I saw the trailer I
was like oh this is something very
different that we're going for here
where not only is it a horror thriller
there might be some really really dark
comedy in there as well and what I got
was such a treatise on interracial
relationships - and the way that other
people might view white people which is
something that I don't think a lot of
people have explored on screen before I
think the impact of it was so powerful
but just as somebody who loves a good
movie this thing was so riveting from
start to finish it's so multi-layered I
think this is a film you can see on
surface level and just enjoy it for the
scares and what it's saying and then you
can really delve into all the
foreshadowing that happens it's a film
that's clever and it's actually my
favorite of the year so far yeah get out
I think we can all agree I mean just
what a pleasant surprise and great film
this film is definitely a game changer
for a lot of reasons Wonder Woman yeah
Wonder Woman I mean as you guys know I'm
not the biggest fan of comic book
superhero films usually I find them
really hard to connect with emotionally
but I surprised myself by watching
Wonder Woman and actually tearing up
because I didn't realize how good it
could feel to see a female superhero on
screen and I think when when you're used
to not seeing yourself reflected
on-screen you forget how powerful it is
and when you watch the movie just
playing out as a comic book
it has so many great moments and it
really felt like a throwback which is
particularly important for the DCE you
because what gal gadot is able to do as
Wonder Woman and the chemistry that her
and Chris pioneered time was wonderful
it was a nice breath of fresh air for a
lot of reasons right on another one that
both of you have on your list it comes
at night it comes at night with
something that that is a movie that is
so good it made me want to go back and
revisit and much shamah onto the village
because my biggest brought with the
village is it I was sold one movie from
the trailers and I got something
completely different and as the numskull
I was at the time maybe I was very upset
that I didn't get the monster movie I
thought it comes at night same situation
where I felt like the trailers were
selling me one movie but what the
difference is here is that once I got
into that other film and I clearly
realized this is where we're going with
this I was so impressed with what Trevor
Schulz was able to do I loved it I
thought it's extremely tense it sets up
its post-apocalyptic world really really
thoroughly although you don't get all
the answers and I like that I like the
movie you can go and see and then talk
about later with your friends so let's
go back and forth and cherry-pick some
films from each of your lists now Alicia
you've got to film that I haven't heard
of until you presented it as one of your
favorites of the year it's Japanese
animated film called your name yeah this
film actually came out in a lot of
places around the world last year but we
only got it this year it's directed by
Makoto Shinkai and it's essentially a
body swap animation where these two
averages classic promise so takes that
trope but then it turns it on its head
so it's these two strangers who keep
waking up in each other's bodies a boy
and a girl and then they form this
really beautiful connection with each
other even though they don't really know
each other they're trying to figure out
who they are why this is happening and
how to possibly get to each other it's
beautiful and animation is breathtaking
mark right off the bat you love a film
on your list which I also love and I'm
sure many of you love Logan Logan it's
it's it's between that right now and
Wonder Woman for my favorite superhero
movie for sure but maybe even favorite
movie of the year so far because Logan
did something that I didn't expect - yes
I wanted to see Hugh Jackman's Wolverine
come back to prominence after the
Wolverine was
I still had a little bit of the taste of
x-men origins in my head yeah they got
the r-rating thanks to Deadpool and now
we have a movie that can do well with
that rating with that amount of violence
yeah better axe dropping that bomb come
right from the start of the movie I was
so hooked emotionally on the storyline
between Wolverine and his young pal even
seen the movie I won't ruin it but it's
just that it really got me for sure I
feel that you have on your list that I
haven't seen yet but it's on my list of
highly anticipated baby driver talk to
me about why that major top 10 so far
yeah I've been lucky enough to see this
film twice already and I can't wait to
see it again it remains one of my
favorites because it's so fresh and
original and fun edgar wright of course
is the director behind the Cornetto
trilogy and Scott Pilgrim vs. the world
this is not so much a comedy it's an
action thriller and a getaway heist
movie where Ansel Elgort has tinnitus or
temperature so of you say with the
ringing in the ear so he plays music to
drown it out the coolest thing is all
the action scenes are set to music so
everything is choreographed whether it's
the driving or the shooting great cast
or together and it's the kind of movie
you want to see with friends in a packed
movie theater and then buy the
soundtrack afterwards and then mark
another one that you have on your list
talk to me about the Belko experiment
the experiment is movies it's very
polarizing because I know there's some
people that saw it and hated it thought
it was stupid or over-the-top I love
this movie so you basically have a
building full of people and one by one
they start getting picked off and we
don't know what's happening but we know
that it's some sort of experiment that
weird mysterious higher-ups are
performing on this select group of
people that's like Hunger Games in an
office really yeah the office space meet
die hard yeah it was so much fun because
this movie does that rare thing where it
made me feel like I was in this
situation with these people and I was
questioning who I would be which
character would I be on screen how would
I handle this very dire situation it was
very different very original and I also
felt like maybe a dr. claw from
Inspector Gadget was behind every year
doctor ha reference you get it I love it
at least another film that may not have
gotten as much press but you loved
personal shopper I really loved this in
this is also polarizing film it's
directed by Olivier Assayas it's a
French film starring Kristen Stewart she
plays a personal shopper to a celebrity
who's also somewhat of a medium and
she's in Paris trying to contact her
dead twin brother and she goes to these
different locations and she summons
things that might not be her brother it
goes really out there and I think that's
what the can audiences had trouble
handling but I thought it was a very
unique ghost story it's got a cool vibe
and also very thrilling and the moments
when I looked away for sure oh and Mark
you have a delightful film on your list
Lego Batman it's fun for a Batman movie
and they really play on the Batman Joker
relationship the best I've seen that
done since Batman the Animated Series
but the best part about this film is it
is one of the better spoof movies that
I've seen since the glory days of spoof
movies in the 80s and early 90s mean
this was a throwback to airplane and top
secret and a gun and hotshots as much as
anything I've seen yes sir Alicia talked
to me about the big sick the big sick
actually comes out this week and I'm so
excited to see it again it's a romantic
comedy-drama written by Kumail Nanjiani
and his wife Emma levy Gordon and it's
all based on a true story of how they
met also star Zoe Kazan who plays
Emily's role very funny very sweet
telling some truths there about
relationships about interracial
relationships and also dealing with
illness mark you look film on your list
that I haven't seen you talk to me about
flight flight is a magnificent
independent film that came out that
really has a superhero vibe a little bit
of coming-of-age and it felt a lot like
the movie dope the comedy but also had
the elements that you get as far as
somebody who is discovering something
new about themselves and in slight it's
this mysterious power that we're
watching and witnessing if somebody
tries to get out of the drug scene and
into being a good human being and
watching the journey that they go on I
thought it was so well done it feels a
little bit like Ironman with a lot of
different twists thrown in you know what
I'm sold
Alicia another film that I haven't seen
yet in Australian film the Berlin
Syndrome oh yeah barely
syndrome this one is a kidnap thriller
it stars Teresa Palmer who plays an
Australian tourist in Berlin she meets
this guy they go out on a date she bumps
into him again they go out again she
goes back to his house and then she gets
locked into his house so it's really
scary very very tense everything she
does is something that you would
probably do if you were in that
situation that's what makes it so
terrifying looking forward to checking
this out mark you have another film on
your list that I really enjoyed as well
and maybe it's a return to form for M
night split oh man split just kicked off
the year so well because we're coming
off a pretty cool year for horror movies
in 2016 lifted something that totally
blew my mind the ending the twist is
fantastic even without that I thought
the movie was great on its own and this
really dark twisted story that has some
some supernatural har elements to it
these are the kind of movies that I want
to see M night continue to do yeah and
James McAvoy have you asked what a
performance huh amazing someone's coming
for you and you're not gonna like it
Alicia give one more on your list that
I'm really looking forward to Sofia
Coppola is the beguiled
yeah this one also comes out this week
it is a twisty turny delicious film set
in the Civil War
great cast Nicole Kidman plays the head
of a and all-female school school for
women and this injured soldier comes by
their place they look after him and then
things take a turn for the dark loosely
based on the 1971 Clint Eastwood film
but I loved it we know that she can do
some masterful work with female ensemble
cast and I'm just you know her debut
film The Virgin Suicides exactly the
other fashion suicide feel for sure and
it tames her back together with many
actors that she's worked with before
great absolutely okay put me on the spot
what is your biggest disappointment of
the year so far well I think we say it
was Kong Skull Island just because of
that cast the cast is so brilliant and I
felt really that they were underused
yep that's a great point mark I get
bummed when a cast is underused but I
get more bummed when a movie just
completely misses the tone of what
you're trying to capture
the mummy was what was in this fire
there was so much potential in there
just like this is the first time I've
ever been watching a Tom Cruise movie
and I'm like I just don't think that
this dude belongs in this movie you're
no longer for me ah I hear you but you
know what wasn't disappointing you guys
talking about your favorite movies of
the year
Oh what's your favorite movie of the
year so far what's your top 10 let us
know in the comments section below we
want to know I want to thank Alicia
Malone check out our book backwards and
in heels and Mark Ellis check them out
touring doing stand-up comedy and on the
collider collision on July 7 that
happens to be my birthday as well yeah
by the way today is my birthday June
we're kind of plugging my birthday right
oh sorry thanks for watching screen
junkies I'm Hal Rudnick hit me up on
Twitter and wish me happy birthday
bye bye
[Music]